[Applause]
if rob gronkowski
calls me out and says you want to box
i'ma go no
i'm [ __ ] if you're asking me to box
right
yeah that's it simple as that actually i
don't know if roblinkowski's nice at
boxing but that [ __ ]
let me ask you a question if you called
out jay-z so it'll be [ __ ] if jay-z
didn't respond to him no because jay-z
got tits
he's not nobody built worse than jay-z's
ever look cool in a candid picture if he
not posing for the picture
he looks ridiculous he human big bird he
got the skinny ass
is the coolest person on the planet
you've never seen something so cool in
your
life and the reason he is that is
because he is the
most uncool person on the planet and
learned how to be cool
trust me you hear his voice cracking his
[ __ ] what about
60 years old
what about the elevator what about the
elevators you know he was
he wasn't on camera he was calm he was
calm and cool yeah
cool like cool like that like a synonym
for calm he's 100
maybe the coolest guy on earth but in
terms of like cool being like swag or
whatever the [ __ ]
no no
i know how we want him to be the
character he betrays
but when you see him on a jet ski with a
helmet
i've got some reasonable doubt that he's
a cool guy because he's trying to be
i got some reasonable safe is it cool
hold on when is safety been cool hey let
me put on this [ __ ] life vest
while i'm on a jet ski that's cool come
on now
motorcycles are cool because how safe
they are yeah that's how it works
raw sexy that's just like
that's just black had a [ __ ] volvo
you would think he was cool
there's airbags on all the doors it's
sweet engineering
come on i'll say it in a way you'll
understand that's just the next level of
a netflix special
what's that you got a netflix special
and you stopped riding your bike because
oh my god this is too dangerous so i
gotta go
take ubers until this [ __ ] is done now
times that by billion
i gotta put a helmet on on a jet ski now
give a context to that give context that
what i'm you're not gonna put your like
your point is valid i'm just saying
people don't
won't understand what you're saying so
we were shooting special right
netflix had a shoulder special and we
were and we were
we've got to be careful with our wording
and uh and i
take a motorcycle to work every day yeah
right yeah i take a motorcycle
electric motorcycle because i care about
the environment i take it with pedals
35 miles an hour exactly no i mean my
[ __ ] goes 60 now so i'll cover yeah
shout out to hawk i got the hulk cycle
the big dog
all right with the electric okay i
stopped taking the motorcycle to work
every day
yeah because i didn't want y'all to miss
out an opportunity to work on a netflix
special yes i mean schultz special
yes right no in all seriousness i took
in all serious i took the motorcycle to
work today or every single day because i
was like god forbid i get in a [ __ ]
accident
and then we can't shoot and push this
day off let me just take an uber yeah
what you're saying is and i agree with
your point you're saying is when you're
with a billion dollars
you can't risk getting an injury on a
[ __ ] jet ski on a jet ski
yeah i mean if you get injured on a jet
question son you can get it jonah jesse
how are you getting the entrance on this
there's water everywhere it's water you
fall into the water bro
son there was times i was doing it i was
trying to do lifts and [ __ ] like that
lips bro he's got a helmet on he could
do everything
what is he hitting his head on in the
water bro bro he can't drown bro his
titties will make him fly yeah
yeah chill out [ __ ] out that
let me ask you a question i got 99
problems and puberty's won
if jay-z wants to fight we go on triller
all right i'll fight him
pay-per-view baby come on he used to do
tybo
now you on board using ether lines
against the
topo all right
i'm gonna say why can't you love him but
he not be the coolest guy on earth
yeah what's wrong with it i love jay-z
but i also understand i think he's a
[ __ ] genius
i don't think he's the coolest guy to
realize
we're gonna start to realize what i
think is cool about him is not the swag
what i think is cool about his big
business actually he's a [ __ ] jean
he's a [ __ ] poet like that's what i
think is cool about him what i'm trying
to say is
what i think people start to learn is
like especially you've seen this even
within the industry the people that
success
that are successful in entertainment for
a long time
are not the cool [ __ ] they're
the people who learned how to use that
right the ones who are like the real
cool guys the ones who are legit
and then anti all this other [ __ ]
they're back in jail what about people
they get drug addictions
they
there mark i don't know what is there
[ __ ] obama over here
damn i'm taking shots at all his heroes
what's going on
y'all killed that for me so i did not
realize
i thought he was just
everything because he was getting
crucified for every word he said that's
what i'm saying so he would like think
things through
but his but no his inauguration speech
in oh eight that she was amazing
pre-written bro how are you gonna
stutter on a pre-release no than that
you guys he started stuttering more as
he was president for longer you guys are
not
doing the definition of stuttering right
what's that what the [ __ ] did you just
say
he's cool right what are you talking
about we're going back
actually it's a good balance that's a
good idea that's valid snoop is cool
loop is a cool horn i just want to say
one thing about snoop what's up
say something about not only is he not
only is he cool
that [ __ ] is comedian level
funny yes he's
funny i did not think he was funny until
i saw him
host the depaul jake paul it's not even
the jake paul fighting that crazy we
call it the jake paul
jones fight oh my god but i did not
think he's like
he is absolutely cool okay that being
said he had like a spiritual advisor
that was a pimp for a while or something
remember
was his like spiritual advisor i smoked
with him you slept with him
smoked with him oh my god oh my gosh you
spoke
with snoop i have video really
damn no no snoop is that dude bro super
really is that dude man but i think
there's something to what you were
saying like it's hard to be cool and
successful
yes it like to be truly cool to be truly
successful because i feel like being
cool
is the opposite of successful a lot of
times yeah i mean
i i know where you're going with it but
just like like to me
someone that's cool is like oh i don't
really care yes you know what i mean i
have not a care in the world i'm chill
all the time nothing bothers me like
i don't give a [ __ ] about nothing yeah
like carefully and to be successful you
have to give a [ __ ] you have to care
it's hard to not give a [ __ ] and still
get the things that giving a [ __ ] gets
you
yes so finding a balance between that or
finding a way to like tap into things
that are cool but don't remove you from
giving a [ __ ]
because anybody in this business gives a
[ __ ] you know we could act like these
people out here like oh i don't care
about acting i don't care about any of
these things you know yeah the reality
is you gotta handle
it the reality is is uh you're still in
the business
yeah like all these people who complain
about it right but then they still do it
shut the [ __ ] up yeah you want to beat
it you go into the audition you got
deadlines
yeah you got a big i mean i don't you
get it when you get it right
i told mark one day when was you when
you were having your big freak out
whatever gosh i was like yo with the
deadlines coming up everything's
keep going everything's cool like what
are we gonna do everything's behind we
gotta catch we had to deliver three
episodes one day
at eight o'clock right and like they
gave us strict deadlines
by this time this time this time i said
mark is terrified
dove is terrifying i said all right
we're gonna get it by those times so i'm
staying up all night working hard
trying to get it done on time and then
andrew walks in you know 10 o'clock
feeling cool
and i go hey andrew like i didn't really
sleep last night but like we're still
behind on this i don't know what to do
like what should we do because i don't
know about the deadline
and he just looks at me and goes hey
mark no no no no no no no no no no this
is not how it went
this is you annoyed me five different
times already yeah this is you just
[ __ ] yapping the same
well what if we don't get it yeah yeah
it's not like barack obama
okay dude he kept going
what if we don't get it what's going on
what are we going to do
he was stressed stressing and by the
fifth time i just had enough and i just
said
when do you want to what did i say oh no
i was gonna say the other one you said
what'd i say because i did ask you five
times
the first time you just go hey mark we
got the meats
i was like what are you talking about he
goes yo they want the meats
we got the meats i was like how does
that help me
you know what i'm saying you got to go
to the butcher we're the butcher
sorry cobra kai season three ain't out
yet about to be bro and then he comes
and then he comes back and
he comes to me he's like yo when do you
want to turn it in
he's like friday saturday night like
take sunday
we're turning in sunday that's it we're
turning this sunday that's ill
that was so and i'm just laughing me and
mark inside we can't really react
but we're like dying inside because it's
due that day and i know i didn't think
he was actually gonna be able to pull
this [ __ ] up
so he was like yo let's just take take
five minutes go on to the roof or some
[ __ ] like that
i'm like yeah we played soccer on the
roof if you don't get this [ __ ] approved
and we just wasted a half hour playing
soccer on the roof i was gonna be
pissed so i get a call from netflix like
an hour later
and uh and uh
after that call i came into the room i
was like can we do it by saturday
okay bro literally we're on the roof
playing soccer
we all needed some soccer we come down
we get a specimen we get an email from
production they go okay
moving the release date will be
catastrophic for the schedule
catastrophic's the worst what does it
mean realistically i moved it two days
though
it wasn't catastrophic we got it done
you always catastrophic getting covered
in the middle of a [ __ ] production
i'm saying the catastrophe has happened
two-week quarantine pushes it two days
that ain't bad mark that was your
problem he was reading those emails
yeah he would read every [ __ ] evening
instead of editing that's why it's
you